Hay una pieza que no termina de encajar en
todo el asunto del golpe de Estado de Prigozhin.
A estas alturas, habréis leído todo tipo
de análisis y un sinfín de vídeos sobre
el tema... pero todavía hay una pregunta
por responder ¿Qué le prometió Lukashenko
a Prigozhin?
Poneos en la piel del líder de Wagner por
un momento. Estamos a punto de entrar en Moscú.
De repente nos llama Alexander Lukashenko
y nos dice “date media vuelta, vente conmigo
a Bielorrusia y ¡No te preocupes que nadie
te va a matar! ... ¿De verdad os fiaríais?
Quiero decir, si algo caracteriza a Vladímir
Putin es que no le tiembla el pulso a la hora
de intentar matar a sus opositores. Y esto
no es un término metafórico. Que se lo digan
a Alexei Navalny, que estuvo a punto de morir
envenenado... y a tantos otros que no tuvieron
tanta suerte. Y, si hay una persona en este
momento a la que Putin le gustaría ver bajo
tierra... ese es Prigozhin ¿Qué le hace
pensar a este hombre que está seguro en Bielorrusia,
que es un aliado de Rusia? Pues bien... aquí
llega la hipótesis que planteamos en este
vídeo... ¿Y si estamos ante una jugada maestra
de Lukashenko? Por el momento, todos estamos
de acuerdo en que ha sido uno de los mayores
beneficiado de este intento de golpe de Estado,
pero... ¿Cómo de beneficiado? Vamos a decirlo
de forma más osada…
¿Y si, en realidad, Vladímir Putin ha sido
el “pagafantas”, o el “simp” de toda
este asunto... y no lo sabe? Atentos porque
en el vídeo de hoy vamos a tocar muchas claves
que van a hacer que veáis el golpe de Prigozhin
con unos ojos muy distintos ¡Dentro vídeo!
Uno de
nuestros pasatiempos favoritos en internet
es seguir a los propagandistas prorrusos en
Twitter. Todavía siguen pensando que Putin
es un genio de la estrategia: un campeón
del ajedrez en 4 dimensiones. Y con tal de
justificar que Putin es un genio de la estrategia,
son capaces de hacer auténticas piruetas
de gimnasia mental. Atentos a este meme que
ha circulado estos días.
¡Claro! Ahora resulta que, en realidad, Prigozhin
estaba siguiendo los dictados de Putin para
terminar a 100 kilómetros de Kiev... ¡Jugada
maestra!
A ver, angelicos míos... si Putin quisiera
enviar a las tropas de Wagner a la frontera
con Kiev... ¡No habría necesitado fingir
un golpe de Estado y arriesgar su posición
interna! Además... ¿Qué sentido tendría?
Perdonad que me ría pero... ¿Qué sentido
tiene volver a intentar tomar Kyiv con 25.000
tropas?
En febrero de 2022, con casi 200.000 soldados
armados hasta los dientes, hicieron el ridículo.
Ahora, con muchas menos tropas... ¿Van a
mejorar el resultado? ¡Pues menuda jugada
de ajedrez! Vamos a ver, mis queridos fanboys
de Putin, entiendo que la fe mueve montañas,
pero esto ya es un chiste. Da igual como lo
mires, el golpe de Estado de Prigozhin no
tiene absolutamente ninguna lectura buena
para Rusia ¡Ninguna! Podemos discutir sobre
si es bueno o malo para Ucrania, pero... está
claro que Putin ha sido el mayor perjudicado
de todo esto. Pero vale, eso ya lo sabemos.
La pregunta ahora es... ¿Quién es el mayor
BENEFICIADO? Pues, en este caso, no hay muchas
dudas: Alexander Lukashenko, el dictador de
Bielorrusia. Por el momento, se ha erigido
en el salvador de la Rusia de Putin. Pero...
¿Y si, en realidad, se ha estado aprovechando
del descontrol de Putin? Por resumir esta
historia en términos twitteros... Antes pensábamos
que Putin era un chad. Ahora estamos viendo
que, en realidad, es un SIMP de manual o,
como decimos en España, un pagafantas. Y
diréis ¿Por qué? ¿Por qué decimos que
Lukashenko se ha beneficiado tanto de este
golpe de Estado? ¿Por qué decimos que el
desastre para Putin puede ser aún mayor de
lo que pensábamos... y le pone en una posición
de pagafantas frente a Bielorrusia? Hoy vamos
a responder a estas preguntas.
[Pero antes, si te gusta lo que hacemos y
quieres ayudarnos a crecer, puedes sumarte
a nuestra comunidad de Patreon. Además de
contribuir con este proyecto recibirás también
un montón de contenido extra, como el boletín
“Las Claves de la Semana”, nuevos vídeos
y merchandising exclusivo.
Muchas gracias a los que ya nos echáis una
mano formando parte de esta comunidad. Os
dejo el enlace en la descripción
Y ahora sí, continuemos. Vamos a ver un poco
de historia.]
(UN DICTADOR MUY RESILIENTE)
Para quien no lo conozca, Alexander Lukashenko
es el dictador que domina Bielorrusia con
mano de hierro desde 1994. Uno de los pocos
dictadores que ni siquiera se esfuerza en
ponerse una careta de democrático. De hecho,
ha llegado a presumir de su condición de
dictador con frases como esta.
C1(“Es mejor ser dictador que gay” –Alexander
Lukashenko)
Pues bien, cuando empezó la guerra de Ucrania,
todos esperábamos que la economía de Bielorrusia
colapsaría. Pensadlo así: Bielorrusia también
ha sido sancionada por Occidente, pero, a
diferencia de Rusia, no tienen ni gas ni petróleo.
La principal exportación de este país de
9 millones de habitantes es... ¡Los fertilizantes!
Eso y algo de tecnología. Por ejemplo, ¿Os
suena el videojuego “World of tanks”?
Pues... está hecho en Bielorrusia. O, al
menos, lo estaba.
(La empresa más grande de videojuegos de
Bielorrusia abandona el país... y Rusia.
El desarrollador del juego de guerra “World
of Tanks” cierra sus estudios y traslada
la operativa de los juegos. Polygon)
Para que os hagáis una idea, desde las protestas
de 2020, más de 20.000 trabajadores del sector
IT han abandonado Bielorrusia.
Estas cifras son una auténtica barbaridad
si tenemos en cuanta que esta industria concreta
tiene un total de entre 60 y 100.000 trabajadores.
Vamos, que Bielorrusia está perdiendo a más
del 20% de sus trabajadores más cualificados.
A estas alturas, podemos decir que los únicos
sectores económicos que quedan vivos en el
país son los fertilizantes y alguna metalurgia.
Y el problema es ¿Cómo pueden exportar esos
productos? Bielorrusia no tiene salida al
mar. Y antes, incluso, de que empezara la
guerra de Ucrania, Lituania ya les había
prohibido utilizar el puerto de Klaipeda.
(El puerto de Klaipeda era la principal salida
de los fertilizantes de Bielorrusia. Sin eso,
la economía entera estaba al borde del colapso.
De hecho, en sólo 1 año, las exportaciones
de Bielorrusia hasta la Unión Europea cayeron
en un 45%. De hecho, fijaos en esta gráfica.
Si os fijáis, tras el anuncio del cierre
del puerto de Lituania a Bielorrusia, la divisa
del país cae. Después llega la guerra de
Ucrania y las sanciones de Occidente... y
se desploma. Y... de repente, en julio de
2022... ¡Vuelve a remontar casi de forma
milagrosa! Sí, es cierto, desde entonces,
sigue cayendo lentamente. Por supuesto, los
controles de capital han jugado un papel clave,
pero estos no han sido su único “escudo”.)
Para que os hagáis una idea, algunas predicciones
apuntaban a que el PIB de Bielorrusia caería
en un 10% en 2022. Sin embargo, esta caída
se quedó en el 4,7%. Sigue siendo una crisis
enorme... pero no es el agujero que cabría
esperar. Y diréis ¿Por qué? ¿Qué ha hecho
Bielorrusia para evitar un armageddon? Lo
podemos resumir en una frase: ¡Rusia al rescate!
¡Habéis oído bien! Rusia ha hecho todo
lo posible por ayudar a su aliado.
Por ejemplo, le han cedido todos sus puertos
para qué pueden retomar las exportaciones.
¡No solo eso! Minsk va a construir su propio
puerto en territorio ruso. Gracias a esto,
pueden seguir exportando sus fertilizantes
a países como China o Brasil ¡Pero no solo
eso! Rusia ha ofrecido generosísimas líneas
de crédito al país. Y, como buen aliado,
la ha dado preferencia para las importaciones.
Es decir, que los rusos ahora importan más
productos bielorrusos que antes. Concretamente,
un 40% más que antes de la guerra.
Esto ha servido para absorber el shock que
supuso la caída de las exportaciones a la
Unión Europea. Y, por supuesto, todo esto
con unos precios de gas y petróleo que son
la envidia de toda Europa. Y, creedme, esto
lo han notado todos los ciudadanos. Fijaos,
sin ir más lejos, en los precios de la gasolina.
¡Dicho de otra forma! Bielorrusia lo está
pasando mal, pero no tanto como cabría esperar.
Y todo esto es gracias a Rusia ¡Pero esperad
un momento porque no sólo hablamos de economía!
Atentos.
T2(UN DICTADOR... CON PIES DE BARRO)
A diferencia de Putin, Lukashenko sí tiene
una oposición conocida y organizada. Y es
que veréis, en el año 2020 celebraron “elecciones”
Unas elecciones tan fraudulentas como cabría
esperar... pero con una diferencia. En este
caso sí había una candidata en la oposición
a Lukashenko: SVIATLANA TSIKHANOUSKAYA. Y
esta mujer sí consiguió galvanizar un movimiento
de oposición que se tradujo en protestas
masivas contra la dictadura. Por supuesto,
Lukashenko respondió con la brutal represión
que cabría esperar. De hecho... atentos a
esta gráfica.
Sin embargo, ahora mismo, Tsikhanouskaya está
en el exilio en Lituania. Desde ahí, está
organizando un movimiento de oposición muy
bien articulado. Para que os hagáis una idea,
tienen incluso una app que se llama “New
Belarus”. Desde ahí, coordinan a todos
los bielorrusos en el exilio.
Mientras tanto, Lukashenko no tiene mucho
poder para evitar un levantamiento serio.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el ejército
bielorruso está en condiciones muy parecidas
a las que tenía el ucraniano antes de 2014.
Armamento soviético, muchísima corrupción
y... muy pocos efectivos. Para que os hagáis
una idea, se calcula que el ejército bielorruso
esté formado por apenas unos 50.000 soldados.
Y eso no es todo, de estas tropas se estima
que sólo 17.000 estarían actualmente entrenados
y preparados para el combate. Y eso siendo
generosos. Muchas fuentes reducen aún más
esta estimación, a una horquilla de entre
6.000 y 10.000 efectivos.
Y para colmo ni siquiera está muy claro que
sean 100% leales a Lukashenko.
De hecho, una de las razones por las que este
país no ha enviado tropas a Ucrania es porque
el dictador sabe que no puede presionar a
sus generales. Sí, es cierto, Bielorrusia
ha permitido que las tropas rusas pasen por
su territorio nacional. Pero hasta ahí termina
la ayuda que le prestan. Y, de hecho... atentos
a esta noticia.
(Las fuerzas rebeldes en Bielorrusia cortan,
parcialmente, la ruta de ferrocarril que lleva
a Ucrania. Forbes)
¡Ya lo véis! Lukashenko ni siquiera puede
evitar sabotajes en su propio territorio.
Y la pregunta es... ¿Cómo se puede mantener
una dictadura con semejantes pies de barro?
La respuesta está en una frase: ¡Rusia,
al rescate!
(Vladimir Putin ha ofrecido enviar asistencia
militar para apoyar al presidente de Bielorrusia,
Alexander Lukashenko, mientras 200.000 manifestantes
se reúnen para pedir su dimisión. Business
Insider)
Esta fue la ayuda de Putin cuando Lukashenko
estaba contra las cuerdas en el año 2020
¡Pero mirad lo que están haciendo ahora!
(Bielorrusia comienza a recibir los envíos
de armas nucleares rusas. Reuters)
¡Habéis oído bien! Bielorrusia ya está
bajo el paraguas nuclear de Rusia ¡No sólo
eso! Para cuando veáis este vídeo, Bielorrusia
ya tendrá armas nucleares para defender su
territorio. Y todo esto, regalito de Vladímir
Putin. La pregunta es... ¿Todo este apoyo
sale gratis? Evidentemente no ¿Cuál es el
precio? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T3(ESTAREMOS JUNTOS... ALGÚN DÍA)
En 1991, Bielorrusia se independizó de la
Unión Soviética. Pero... Moscú nunca terminó
de creerse que este país iba a ser libre
y soberano por mucho tiempo. Ya en 1999, con
BORIS YELTSIN como presidente, Bielorrusia
firmó un acuerdo para el llamado “Estado
de la Unión”. Esto significa que algún
día, Rusia y Bielorrusia se unirían en una
entidad supranacional llamada “Estado de
la Unión”. Visto así, suena como una especie
de Unión Europea ¿Verdad? Creo que ya os
imagináis que no es así. El nombre sugiere
algo estilo, un matrimonio pero... pensadlo
bien:
Esto es Rusia, el país más grande del mundo
en territorio, con más de 140 millones de
habitantes... y eso de ahí es... (DICHO CON
DESPRECIO) Bielorrusia. Claramente, no era
un matrimonio entre iguales, sino un contrato
de sumisión pura y dura. Un intento de que
Bielorrusia se convirtiera en una región
rusa más. Y hay una cosa que tenemos que
tener clara:
Lukashenko puede ser un tirano malvado y despiadado...
¡Pero no es tonto! Y no está dispuesto a
perder su poder. Así que estos dos países
firmaron el acuerdo... pero, desde entonces,
no han dado ningún paso en la dirección
de unirse ¡No solo eso! Putin ha llegado
a presionar a Lukashenko usando su mayor arma
económica: gas y petróleo. Y el dictador
bielorruso ha llegado a plantarle cara llegando
a cosas como esta.
(14 de febrero 2020: Bielorrusia amenaza con
desviar el gas ruso que se quiera enviar a
Europa)
¡Habéis oído bien! No es una broma. Bielorrusia
llegó a amenazar con robar el gas ruso que
se enviaba a Europa y que pasaba por su territorio.
Sin embargo, esto es del año 2020. Concretamente
de ANTES de las protestas contra Lukashenko.
En este momento, este dictador pensaba que
tenía una posición de fuerza. Pero luego
llegaron las macroprotestas y en Misk se dieron
cuenta de que un dictador sólo tiene poder
si cuenta con músculo militar que le apoye.
Sin eso... no hay nada que hacer. Así que
cuando Lukashenko se vio contra las cuerdas,
no le quedó otro remedio que bajarse los
pantalones delante de Putin y decir “lo
que tu quieras, Papi”. Y así ha sido la
relación entre estos dos países en los últimos
dos años. Llegando a extremos como este.
(Documentos filtrados muestran la estrategia
de Rusia para anexionarse Bielorrusia en 2030.
The Moscow Times)
Sin embargo... atentos porque ahora las cosas
han cambiado. De nuevo: Lukashenko puede ser
malo pero no es tonto. Y sabe ver las oportunidades.
Aquí llega el plot twist que nadie se esperaba.O
B
T4(¿QUIÉN ES EL PAGAFANTAS AQUÍ?)
El 24 de junio de 2023, los mercenarios del
grupo Wagner se plantan a unos cientos de
kilómetros de Moscú. En cuestión de horas,
los vuelos para marcharse de Moscú se agotan.
Los moscovitas están aterrados por lo que
parece el inicio de una guerra civil. Hablamos
de casi 25.000 tropas sublevadas que están
avanzando por territorio ruso como Pedro por
su casa. Y os preguntaréis ¿Podrían haber
llegado a tomar Moscú? Lo más probable es
que no. Pero está claro que, de haber seguido
con la marcha, habría sido un auténtico
baño de sangre. Y entonces, cuando Putin
estaba realmente contra las cuerdas... y entonces
ocurre lo siguiente. Lo que vais a oír ahora
es, literalmente, la conversación telefónica
que el propio Lukashenko dice que tuvo con
Putin.
--¡Venga Putin! ¿Cómo vas a “liquidar”
a los amotinados? Vamos a hablar con Prigozhin
y sus comandantes...
--Mira, Shasha... ¡Que es que ni me coje
el teléfono! ¡Que ya no quiere hablar conmigo!
Y entonces, llega Lukashenko y llama a Prigozhin.
Minutos más tarde, Wagner dice que se retira
de Moscú y que se va... ¡A Bielorrusia!
Y horas más tarde, el Kremlin dice lo siguiente.
(Rusia retira las acusaciones criminales contra
Prigozhin tras la rebelión de Wagner. NY
Times)
Durante los siguientes días, Prigozhin está
en paradero desconocido. A la vez, Rusia dice
que todos los mercenarios de Wagner que NO
participaron en el motín tienen las puertas
abiertas en el ejército regular. Pero recordad
que Prigozhin tenía entre su mando cuando
da el golpe a entre 20.000 y 25.000 militares.
Y diréis ¿Pueden ser leales unos mercenarios?
Pues... probablemente mucho más de lo que
podríamos pensar.
De entrada, le han apoyado en su intento de
golpe de Estado. Pero además, pensad una
cosa: Prigozhin ha reclutado a exoficiales
del ejército ruso pagándoles sueldos estratosféricos
¡Pero no sólo eso! También ha reclutado
a expresidiarios. Y diréis ¿Puede ser leal
un expresidiario? La respuesta es que sí.
Y mucho. Hablamos de gente con vidas totalmente
destruidas. Gente sin familia ni futuro a
los que, un buen día, Prigozhin les ofreció
una segunda oportunidad. Pasar de ser criminales
a ser héroes de su patria. A lo largo de
la historia hemos visto montones de cuerpos
de élite que se han creado con una filosofía
muy parecida. Dicho de otra forma, que Prigozhin
no está solo. Y Lukashenko lo sabe. Y por
eso Lukashenko no solo está recibiendo al
líder de los Wagner en su país... sino a
todo su séquito.
(“Nos van a informar sobre las armas: cuales
funcionaron, cuales no funcionaron. Y las
tácticas, y el armamento, y cómo atacar,
cómo defenderse... esto no tiene precio.
Y esto es lo que necesitamos tomar de los
“wagneritas”. –Alexander Lukashenko)
Y lo cierto es que razón no le falta. Los
mercenarios de Wagner son unas auténticas
bestias: responsables de las torturas más
salvajes que os podáis imaginar. Pero una
cosa es cierta: son prácticamente los únicos
que han logrado alguna victoria para el bando
ruso en Ucrania. Y eso explica noticias como
esta.
(Bielorrusia está construyendo un campo para
los miembros de Wagner trasladados. National
Review)
¡Ya lo véis! Lukashenko no está perdiendo
el tiempo. Y alguno dirá ¿Pero de dónde
van a sacar el dinero para manteniendo a estos
guerreros? Al fin de cuentas, sin los contratos
que tenía Wagner con el Kremlin... ¿Quién
les va a pagar el sueldo?
(Pues bien, si sois veteranos seguidores de
VisualPolitik ya sabéis que Wagner no sólo
está en Ucrania. También está muy activo
en África, donde no cobran en dinero sino
en especie. Wagner controla varias minas en
África. Hablamos de oro y otros recursos
por valor de miles de millones de dólares.
Todo ese dinero ya no va a llegar al Kremlin...
sino a los bolsillos de Wagner. Dicho de otra
forma: es muy probable que las cuentas de
Prigozhin estén tan saneadas como las del
mismísimo Putin)
¿Y dónde está Prigozhin ahora? ¡Exacto!
En Minsk, la capital de Bielorrusia ¿Y qué
necesitaba Lukashenko para plantarle cara
a cara con Putin? ¡Exacto! Músculo militar.
Antes decíamos que Bielorrusia sólo cuenta
con un ejército de menos 50.000 unidades
activas y que están mal entrenadas y mal
armadas. Ahora acaban de recibir entre 20.000
y 25.000 tropas con experiencia de combate
y bien entrenadas.
Y ya sé lo que me diréis alguno ¡Pero Fonseca!
¿Quién garantiza que Prigozhin vaya a ser
leal a Lukashenko? La respuesta es... ¡Las
circunstancias! Wagner no puede volver a Rusia...
¡Pero necesitan estar en algún lugar! Pocos
países les van a ofrecer asilo... Salvo Bielorrusia.
Es decir, q ue por el momento, Lukashenko
y Prigozhin tienen muy buenas razones para
llevarse bien. Y, por supuesto, cuando Putin
se ha dado cuenta de esta jugada, ya es demasiado
tarde...
Después de todo lo que hemos visto, sólo
hay una cosa clara: Putin se acaba de convertir
en el pagafantas de Lukashenko. Primero le
ha dado dinero y apoyo político. Luego le
ha enviado armas nucleares. Ahora le ha regalado
un ejército privado. La pregunta es... ¿Vamos
a ver cómo la tensión entre Rusia y Bielorrusia
se vuelve a recrudecer? ¿Intentará Putin
retirar las armas nucleares que YA ha instalado
en Bielorrusia? ¿Quién tiene más poder
en este momento... Putin o Lukashenko? Podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí, en VisualPolitik,
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo. Un
saludo y hasta pronto.